this man was back out on the practice
field today when nobody thought that
could be possible when he got hurt
earlier this year but you never count
him out and we are thrilled to have him
here on the rich eisen show in advance
of the arizona cardinals taking on the
los angeles rams in the finale to super
wild card weekend he is the all world jj
watt how are you jj
i'm good rich how are you doing i'm
doing better for talking to you so how
does it feel to be back out there on a
practice feels good it feels really good
it feels good to be back with the guys
feels good to be back
on the grass uh the weather is beautiful
out here so it was great to be out there
okay uh your your coach called you very
limited uh would that be the uh
uh
how you would uh determine jj i'm not
i'm not gonna say anything until monday
night i'm just gonna
we're just gonna let it progress as it
progresses and we're gonna do what we
need to do over here and uh we'll see
what happens okay so throughout this
process um when you it first happened
were you just thinking right from the
start this thing's not over is that the
way it goes for you jj um well i had to
figure out exactly what it was first and
once we figured out what it was there's
obviously um getting the opinions and
trying to figure out exactly what it
means and
i mean my very first thought was
obviously that's it it's over
but then
then the competitor and you kicks in and
the
uh the optimist and you kicks in and you
try and figure out okay let's let's see
what we can do here because there's i
mean even if you can't come back there's
the best way to attack it is with the
mindset that you can come back faster so
it's been uh it's been a process there's
been a lot of people helping me out a
lot of great people and
there's been a lot of days where we're
just grinding and so when did you first
begin to realize this is entirely
possible
for me to make it back in time for the
planet
me earlier than probably the doctors and
the trainers i would say but uh
you know early on you know there's a
belief there's just some things where
there's certain checkpoints that you hit
obviously along the way in a recovery
process and once you start hitting
checkpoints
earlier than expected
then you start to be like oh maybe this
thing can happen and as it goes and it
goes it just we start hitting more and
more checkpoints quicker and quicker
okay and then uh all right this is
i i i loved your tweet when the word
first came out that you were being
activated the predator that was a good
one you got the schwarzenegger predator
thing going on so i appreciate it
what was that i got a laugh from you
rich that's really easy
you definitely gotta laugh for me that
you put the predator out there because
that was means that i i'll be very
honest with you that's when i thought
this is real
honestly the 2022 the meme of a predator
on twitter is
that's official news no but i i i
honestly thought to myself you would not
have done that if if this wasn't real
like you know what i mean like
this wasn't this is no this is all in
it's really i honestly thought that jj
it's a fair assessment uh okay i also
could have just been
trying to make people laugh well there
you go but it does seem like this thing
is is is real what is the the sense
around this locker room right now now
that you are in the tournament it's
kyler murray's first go-round in this
tournament you've been there and done
that uh what is your general sense as
somebody who has been there and done
that of this
locker room and the sensibility of of
having the tournament in front of you jj
we have a good understanding of what
what needs to happen and what needs to
be done um nobody in the locker room
will tell you that we finished the
season the way we wanted to there's no
denying that
we did not do what we wanted to do in in
the back half of the season but we know
what we are capable of when we all play
together and when we all do what
uh we're capable of and we play with an
edge and we play with confidence and we
go out there and we overcome adverse
situations and we we're the team we know
we can be um and so that's our sole
focus is putting that team on the field
on monday night
the team that we know we are fully
capable of being and uh you know
obviously we saw what you the the
defense looked like when you were active
early on week one jumps to mind
especially since that was against the
eventual
top seed in the afc tennessee chandler
jones went off what has he been like for
you to be a teammate with and watch from
afar as you were rehabbing jj i've
enjoyed it i've enjoyed being with chan
you know chan's a big uh unbelievably
athletic smart talented kid he's got a
great personality he's got a great sense
of humor
he's he's always making guys laugh he's
always talking ball
he always wants to talk about pass rush
moves and talk about
you know hand placement footwork all
these types of things and uh it's been
great i've really enjoyed being around
when how do you you know so you just
called him kid i mean you're you're in
this role you're the og jj i just heard
that i just picked that one up i just
heard that
we're like brothers man like he he
yesterday in the weight room actually he
called himself the fourth wad brother
jj dj tj and cj
[Laughter]
cj watt that is hilarious
oh my gosh no he's great though it's
been a lot of fun and we love talking
ball we love working together and uh
it's he's a great player i mean the guy
has had an unbelievable career i think
it's been an underrated career and he's
he's been fun to be around hey man just
like you he's part of the 100 plus sack
club man that that's a fact and he has
just been terrific and you know um
we had him on a couple weeks ago he was
hilarious i thought it was hilarious
saying that he is unfollowed uh kyler
murray because kata refuses to do so can
you get can you mediate this thing i
just can't have any dissension leading
up to monday night i know i mean it's
just absolute turmoil um i can't believe
tmz hasn't picked it up yet and
you know there's just
you never know what you're gonna get if
you peel back the layers of that onion
and it just could unravel to pieces so
we're just hoping that doesn't happen
okay you just gotta hold this thing
together there's no question about that
for all the twitter people
oh my gosh
oh what are you doing rich you enjoy
your michigan season this year
well
uh jj if you didn't uh no
yeah
that was all kinds of great that was
great i was living my best life in the
month of december just living my best
life the ohio the fact that the ohio
state
uh buckeyes won a basketball game
against duke three days after losing to
michigan in football so i could come on
this show and congratulate them on being
a basketball school it's one of my
favorite moments maybe of my entire life
i'm not gonna lie you know i'm happy for
you i'm happy you're not come on no no
i'm not but uh
but we got uh
badgers and johnny davis and and badger
basketball is playing very well right
now sure
just we'll see what happens when we run
into you i'm going to be perfectly
honest i don't know if we've already run
into you guys or not no i've been fully
up to date i'm in the same world right
now i'm i'm just basking and i'm you
know we're a football school so i'm
still you know focused
on all of that you know and now i'm
hearing that harbaugh might leave you
know now there's that kind of rich you
gotta pony up uh
the business yes he's gonna say he might
leave so that rich eisen yeah builds the
rich eisen indoor
training facility
production center yeah steven ross and i
are putting a package together right now
so you know yeah the roth eisen
jj it's eisen ross you have no idea of
course i'm sorry okay you have no idea
what did you think of aiden hutchinson
though when you were seeing him he's fun
to watch man he's fun to watch he's a
good player he's uh
he's active he's extreme plays with a
lot of effort played has some great
moves and i think
i think that type of energy that he
plays with is infectious and it's
obviously fun to watch and i think he's
going to be successful at the next level
okay because of that all right did that
hurt you to say that because i mean you
know you just like good football players
i like watching good football players so
even though he wears the wrong colors
has a very interesting eye black pattern
um i i remember i can i can relate my i
don't know he may have a reason behind
it so i don't want to rip on it but my
first when i first got to the nfl uh my
first preseason game ever so in college
i wore like three armbands on each arm i
thought i was awesome
and i got to the nfl in my first
preseason game i put on three armbands
in the locker room and our nose tackles
sean cody looked to me he goes what the
hell are you doing and i was like i'm
getting ready for the game take that off
[Laughter]
yeah that wasn't good that wasn't gonna
fly huh so you think that so you think
the the the facial blah well i mean john
randall did it but i guess he's a hall
of famer right so yeah you can do
whatever you want trust me what i
learned in the league so i i immediately
complied i was the rookie i was not
going to say anything to anybody yeah no
problem i'll take it off but what i
learned in the league is if you play
good you can do whatever the hell you
want i know you could paint your whole
body if you want to if you play good it
doesn't matter what you do okay i love
it jj watt few more minutes left here
with the three-time defensive player of
the year does your brother deserve his
first what do you think pound it pound
that table deserved it last year he's
going to get it this year i mean if he
doesn't i don't know what's going on but
uh
i mean tied the all-time sack record in
the nfl played
only i don't want 14 and a half games i
think he played
22 and a half sacks i mean
the guy
is unbelievable to watch it's a blast to
watch some of his sacks coming in the
most crucial times of the game forced
fumbles to win a game in overtime
setting up his team
to win games i mean i think that if you
look at the stats they were undefeated
when he played the full game and they
were
like two and six when he didn't play the
full game so
he's incredible i'm happy to see them in
the playoffs derek's been playing great
football
on special teams it's been fun to watch
those guys but
i mean what tj did this year and what
he's what he means for that team and
what he is able to do i mean you can't
tell me i know defensive players and
anybody but quarterbacks don't have a
chance to win the mvp but
uh he's he deserves to be in that
conversation as well well again i'm not
saying this to be a fourth watt brother
because clearly we've already
established chandler jones has already
taken that role in cj but your bro got
hosed on the sack record period i don't
know he i mean he
he's he took down huntley after he
fumbled the ball and got it back
and then i mean the rule the rule is
that it's an aborted play if the guy if
there's a fumble and he just falls on it
if it but if he tries to get up and is
going to try to do something right and
the put in the receivers are out in a
pass route that's a sack and what
happened was he picked the ball up
clearly with intent to try and
get up and do something with it right
then tj knocked the ball out so i don't
understand how that's not a sack when
you look at the letter of the law
um and he he'll never say it publicly
because
you don't say it about yourself but i'll
say it for him that that deserved to be
a sack and if you especially if you
compare it to straight hands final sack
i mean yeah
come on
yeah um i i don't think you're wrong um
on that front and i i imagine you were
in the position of all steelers fans on
sunday you know waiting for the result
of sunday night football to not be a tie
and going through all the emotional
rollercoaster of all that right on
sunday night it was crazy yeah it was
crazy obviously i'm in a group text with
my brothers and and we started to
facetime because it got that crazy i
mean
all day long you know my wife and i were
talking through the scenarios and she
was like just talk me through it again
so the students are in and i was like
yeah they're in i mean of course
tonight's game just can't end a tie but
i mean it's not going to end in time
she's like yeah it's not going to end in
a tie
and then you know the game starts and
you start counting off and you're like
okay it's a three-point game that's a
little
a little weary and then it got to 12
points and i was like all right we're
good 12 points i'm gonna go to
to bed and i got it on my phone so i
started watching on my phone i got to i
think then they kicked the field goal so
it was 15. yep and i told my wife i was
like all right 15 points is a little
more shaky
and then
it started to get closer i was like are
you
like is this going to happen right now
and so we both we turn it on and we're
sitting there watching and then it goes
to overtime and i mean
you're like
you got to be kidding me you got to be
kidding me and then they're going to
kneel it out right at the end and then
they call the time i mean
script writers like the nfl
that couldn't have been scripted any
better for week 18 to come down to the
last play for a team to get in i mean
what a unbelievable setup but the fact
is did you think that the raiders were
gonna kneel i don't know like that time
out that the chargers took
it was still around a time where you
know it was taken late enough that the
raiders could still come out and knelt
it down i think they were gonna run it
anyway right but if they didn't get the
first
that would have created uh like just run
the clock out at that point in time yeah
i would imagine the getting of the first
down change changed everything and who
knows maybe they would have tried a
super long field goal anyway just
just to try and win but uh i don't think
that the timeout hurt the raiders that's
that's for sure um all right so uh
before i let you go jj i'm gonna circle
back you know where these things work so
are you come on you're gonna play give
it your best shot are you playing monday
night or not
[Laughter]
are you playing monday night oh
um let's see if i can come up with
something clever here okay there you go
um
you just
no i got nothing clever i can't tell you
you can't tell me because you know or
you just need to go through it and you
don't want to you don't want to uh
poke the uh the football gods here jj
what do you got yeah
to both of those okay rich i think jj's
telling you anything else i can say
to make you
question even more
okay all right there's not um okay all
righty so wait and see
all right so i'll see what we will see
him on i mean
you're getting on the plane you're
getting on the plane so i will see i
will be in los angeles okay they were
there and that's not to shoot the next
season of ultimate tag right no
no it's not come on man although it was
fun that was great my kids my kids say
hey dad you gotta ask jj so i just asked
you it's it's not gonna happen there's
no more that's it that code would really
hurt that one we were set for season two
and then uh covet happened so okay
people chasing people and trying to
physically touch them
[Laughter]
the whole concept is not to be socially
distant i got it i guess the whole world
played a new game of ultimate tag for
the last two years that's it so the
light bulb just went off we're not very
good at it either by the way
we failed the game of all time
jj watt you'd be well sir i look forward
to seeing you playing monday night
all right i appreciate you rich okay uh
we'll talk to you soon all right there
you go that's j.j watt the one and only
at jj watt right here on the rich eisen
show i was really hoping he's playing
monday night i would say yes
why else because what i said coach
called you very limited you know and i
just you know i had to point out that's
what your coach said because all right
so first questions first would you like
to contradict your coach on national
television and radio like he's too smart
to fall for that mousetrap and i wasn't
setting a trap i was just being honest
like hey here you go your coaches are
very limited he kind of chuckled you
hear that one yeah yeah i heard it
i'm just thinking something that jj said
he didn't come all the way back here
exactly
he didn't do all of that
to be
activated and practice and then go yeah
i just you know let's let's
let's let's be a little bit let's let's
just blink that yellow caution light a
little bit and here's some i saw some
i'm looking at practice video right now
on twitter
he's doing a lot of things that someone
who had his injuries like couldn't do
before so
yes
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here